Gareth Thomas sports personality public
figure and basa der for the LGBT
community victim of a hate crime I can't
express how I feel about the perpetrator
because it wouldn't air all I can say is
it's utterly unacceptable to
discriminate against someone for their
sexuality instead of pressing charges
Gareth offered an alternative solution
to his attacker by using restorative
justice I admire him for wanting to come
face-to-face with this miscreant and try
and sort things out but we all know
we're struggling to control you for
today hate crime is just one example
young offenders line the corridors of
adult prisons because the system has no
room elsewhere as opposed the scene of
badges of honor and there are a few
consequences for criminal action my
concern is this young lad won't really
see the error of his ways because he's
got off so lightly I want to see proper
punishments for criminals we need to
adopt a zero-tolerance approach prison
sentences to have people quaking in
their designer trainers I believe
everyone could be rehabilitated but if
we don't get tough on crime crime will
get tough on us well I think this case
is really interesting because I think
Gareth Thomas should be applauded at the
end of the day this was his choice to
opt for this solution and when you look
at why when you look at his reasons as
to why he decided to go for restorative
justice rather than to press charges is
because the I'm not in any way condoning
or in any way and making excuses
sixteen-year-olds behavior but forgave
Thomas he didn't want that kid to end up
with a criminal record that could impact
the rest of that child's life and what
he wanted instead was the option for
that child to be
the error of his ways in a way that
perhaps could be some form of
rehabilitation and if you look at
restorative justice 85% of victims that
took part say that they are satisfied
and actually if you look at the
economics in terms of how much it saves
our criminal justice system it saves an
average they're saying is possible that
seventy thousand cases could deliver as
saving over a hundred and eighty five
million pounds so the fact is we know
that prison doesn't work we know that
actually if you look at when a young
person enters that system chances are
we've lost them and if there's a way to
save them ahead of time why wouldn't we
and i lured him because I don't I'm not
just saying no the only thing I would
add is I personally hope that there is
more at the end of it
for that child is the rehabilitation of
these youngsters off it there's a lot to
be said for community service it has to
mean something you've got to get up at
your scratch or at five o'clock in the
morning and be doing something that's
actually laboring your bones or you're
not learning sometimes a one-on-one with
your victim I mean in this case he he
hasn't met his assailant
yet but in Nigel Owens's case so Nigel
Owen is a another rugby player who's
also a referee sorry referee who's also
gay who was a victim of homophobic
twitter trolling and in his case he
opted for this as well and I think that
actually sometimes when you're brought
face to face with your victim you're
able to absolutely agree well let's see
what Nigel and says in the words of the
man himself I agreed to meet up with him
and you could see that he was sincere an
apologetic for what he had happened
Ronnie and in fact he was he was a very
decent young man and I think this then
was the best way to deal with that now
the issue of a problem can be is there
are some individuals out there and say
that this is the case in Gardez case
whatsoever but there are some
individuals out there who are just nasty
nasty people and sometimes by getting
away with something but just saying
sorry they feel we got away with this
now there's not going to be any
Nigel Owens arguably the best rugby
union ref in the world as someone who
goes to Twix and seeing that every time
he would never give an offside against
New Zealand but that's another matter
hawky because he was never offside
talking about receiving homophobic abuse
on Twitter in 2015 talking to Sky News
and the point there is and he's lived
the life so I can't possibly gain say
Nigel but he's right as long as and I'm
not saying in this case of the Welsh
rugby player that is as long as the
person involved doesn't think I've got
away with it that would be my one
concern all I've got to do is shake hand
sir I'm terribly sorry I actually quite
like gay people then I go down the pub
and laugh and do anything that would be
my some footage of a woman who met her
rapist reliving the moment she met the
man who'd raped her
Joanne nodding thinks it's because of
that face-to-face meeting that she can
now talk so freely about the attack and
her attacker I wanted him to get
something out of it to try and prevent
him from doing it to it to anyone else
because I do think he thought oh I raped
Joe but it was just that one isolated
incident I wanted him to really realize
how he made me suffer and I think that's
what I got through too and I think he
got an awful lot out of it I think
that's why I find it really powerful I
find it really moving and I think that
anything that avoids taking going to
court ending up with prison sentences
ending up with rancor rather than wait
wait wait can I just finish I mean
mediation as opposed to going to court
when you're getting divorced a speed
awareness course rather than the fine
you know all these things are proving to
be better in ways effective
cost-effective restorative justice works
to a point but it needs to be injunction
was something in conjunction with
something else that actually physically
means that they had it suits the
perpetrator and it saves money what's
the problem and and if figures
demonstrate it works I mean I just
wanted to separate between those
defenses that are
if I want to just demonstrate those
offensive the statutory mandate prison
like murder and rape and I imagine if
that man did was convicted of rape she
met him in his prison I don't imagine
he's out free after raping somebody
right so I think let's contextualize
this conversation if you murder someone
raped someone torture someone you're
gonna be in jail and then you implement
restorative justice so that in that case
and in those scenarios or objections
they go to the side because then surely
she has the right to go and face him for
her own mental absolutely she's getting
something from that exhibits not
something to Burnside restorative
justice when the man or woman is already
serving time for their crime and let's
only then speak about like in this case
where a person isn't didn't go to jail I
think in in in relatively minor offenses
and I put that in quotation marks the
only reason I'm saying that it's a 16
year old attacking a rugby rugby captain
isn't like raping a woman I think in
those sorts of instances it should be
not monograph so the victim
no but that's why I said I'm putting in
voluntary in quotation marks it should
be where it's not a mandatory jail term
it should be up to the victim how they
seek to mediate the offense commit and
this is my point about zero tolerance
because a big man isn't somebody for no
reason other than is sexuality that's
where I would say to feel that I think
that if we look at all the studies done
on this as Jun was saying it only
demonstrates he throws a 16 year old in
jail they're gonna come out you know
graduate because Phil said they should
be then getting up at 5 o'clock in the
morning and going out and do something
that's the point having them in high-vis
vest pitting up late being up lit all
right something more substantive the
punishment should but I'm not saying
purely someone has to go to jail every
time ok but there should be something
that what does that person's life to
such an extent that they're not
comfortable helps but I'd also not to
see what you're saying is he needs to do
something actually impacts them whatever
that thing is that still restorative
justice is that if you're not saying
they have to go to jail all you're
really debating is what the nature of
our structures in the casework
we've just seen him having a chat with
him having a word and sound right okay
and then the game's over
nope it's a symptom then also going to
dig in trip [ __ ]